it says that a company makes two types
of computers X&Y the company can make a
total of 80 computers per day and it has
240 work hours available per day it
takes to work hours to make computer X
and six work hours to make computer Y
the profit on computer X is $80 and the
profit on computer Y is 120 dollars how
many of each should be made to maximize
the profit okay so it seems like there's
a lot going on in this problem and there
usually is when you're talking about
these linear programming type problems
but what I recommend doing is just kind
of read it through quickly first and
then go to that last sentence okay
that's what we're trying to optimize
your you're trying to maximize something
or minimize something and what I would
do is write that equation first because
that'll tell us what our variables are
and that'll help to kind of frame the
problem a little bit for us so how many
of each should be made to maximize
profit so let's see what's an equation
for the profit well profit equals $80
times the amount that's made on computer
X okay plus a hundred and twenty dollars
which is made on computer Y so if we can
figure out how many of X&Y tech
computers we should make that'll be the
profit right okay now what we want to do
is we want to work with the constraints
okay the constrictions the restrictions
right so it says you can only make a
total of 80 computers per day okay so
what does that mean it means that X plus
y okay the two types of computers you
can make less than or equal to 80 okay
right okay what other restrictions are
there it only has 240 work hours
available okay so that means you can't
work more than 240 work hours it has to
be less than or equal to 240 work hours
and let's see it takes to work hours to
make computer X so that's 2 X it takes 6
work hours to make computer Y so that's
6 y is less than or equal to 240 now
something that's not always written in
the problem itself is the fact that you
can't really make a negative number of
computers so we have to assume that X is
greater than or equal to 0
can't make a negative number of
computers right and same thing with Y y
is greater than or equal to 0 so these
are our constraints and what we're going
to do is run a graph that's now
look at the region okay the feasible
region that satisfies all these
constraints so let's go ahead and do
that right now let's go ahead and graph
that okay so what we have here is here's
X here's Y now what you want to do when
you graph these is you want to kind of
pay attention to maybe what the X
intercepts and y intercepts are so it
looks like here you're gonna look at 80
it looks like here it could be like
maybe 40 and 120 and let's see so it
looks like maybe we should count by like
20s all right so let's do that so we've
got 20 40 60 80 100 120 same thing here
20 40 60 80 100 120 okay so now what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to set X
to 0 so Y is 80
okay so 20 40 60 80 right there and
let's see if Y is 0 then X is 80 okay
good and so if we graph our line it's
going to look something like this and
this is an inequality you see how it's
less than or equal to 80 if we do a test
point like 0 0 so we put 0 in for X and
0 in for Y so 0 is going to be less than
or equal to 80 so that means that where
this point is here that's the true
region so we want to shade in this
region right here okay all right now the
next one it says 2x plus 6 y is less
than or equal to 240 so if we set X to 0
0 times anything is 0 divided by 6 you
can see our y intercept is going to be
40 so that's 20 40 so that's right there
if we set Y to 0 0 times 6 is 0 so
that's what I'm covering that up so then
if we divide by 2 you can see X is going
to be 120 so that's going to put us
right over here and if we draw that line
looks something like that right and
again if we do a test point like 0 0 is
0 less than or equal to 240 yes that's
true so that means that where this test
point is the origin is going to be on
the true side of the the line so we're
gonna that's going to put us right here
okay
okay so so far you can see that we're in
this overlapping region now we also have
to take into account that X is greater
than equal to zero okay so that means
we're to the right of the y-axis and the
Y has to be greater than or equal to
zero which means we're above the y axis
so you can see that all these regions
all these inequalities are overlapping
right here in the first quadrant okay
now the next thing you want to do is you
want to look at the vertices or the
corners of this polygon that's formed
this region and you can see there's a
point here there's a corner there is a
vertex there there's the origin and
there's there so what we want to do is
we want to find the location of these
points some of these we already know
like this point here is a 80 comma 0
this point here is 0 comma 40 right but
this point here is not so easy to locate
ok it might be 60 20 but what we have to
do is we'll have to take the two
equations here of those lines just treat
them like equations and we'll have to
solve that system to find out where they
intersect so let's go ahead and do that
right now I'm just going to write those
over here and I'm just going to treat
them like equations so we have X plus y
equals 80 right and we've got 2x plus 6y
equals 240 now I'm going to multiply
this top equation by negative 2 okay and
I'm gonna write it down here so that's
negative 2x minus 2y equals negative 160
if we add these together we get 4y
equals 80 right so that means that if we
divide by 4y equals 20 and if we put 20
back in for y here you can see that X is
going to be 60 all right so it looks
like this point here is going to be 60
comma 20 all right so now we've got the
vertices or the corners of this feasible
region okay this polygon here that's
formed the overlapping inequalities and
we want to test these in our profit
equation because we're trying to
maximize profit now sometimes you're
trying to minimize something like cost
and then you would plug in these points
and see which is going to give you the
minimum but we're here we're trying to
maximize so let's go ahead and plug in 0
for T so we put in 0 for X and 40 for y
what does that come out to well we have
a hundred and twenty times forty four
thousand eight hundred so at this point
I'm just going to write profit
equals 4,800 okay that's for this point
right here now let's go over to eighty
zero
so eighty zero would be eighty times
eighty which is what 6400 plus zero so
this point is going to be sixty four
hundred okay and then we're going to
check the sixty twenty points so 60
times 80 is what forty eight hundred
plus twenty that's going to be twenty
four hundred right so that's going to
give us a total of how much seventy
seventy two hundred right so this point
is seven thousand two hundred so it
looks like if we want to maximize our
profit here and still stay within our
restrictions or our constraints we're
going to want to produce sixty of
computer X and twenty computer wise
right and that's going to give you a
maximum profit of seven thousand two
hundred and again staying within the
constraints so a lot of work involved
with these linear programming problems
but I think the key and my opinion is to
just read it through quickly usually go
to that last sentence trying to figure
out what you're trying to maximize or
minimize write that equation first
that'll tell you what your variables are
then you can write all your other
constraint equations in terms of those
you know those variables then go ahead
and graph the region okay find out the
overlapping region and then what you
want to do is look at the vertices of
the corners those are the points that
you'll run on to test in your function
that you're trying to maximize or
minimize in this case was profit and
then whichever one gives you the largest
or the least depending on what you're
trying to do that's going to be what
you're gonna want to aim for so and
that's the gonna be your solution so I
hope this helped you understand how to
work with linear programming problems
better subscribe to the channel check
out more math tutoring videos on my
youtube channel
Mario's math tutoring and I look forward
to helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon